i almost didn't even want to put this
clip up it's so damn juicy but my
friends at tushy said hey man let's rock
it so thanks to tushy for bringing you
this gold
but our house got bigger and bigger as
we grew up
you know dad became more and more
successful as we grew up in the house
and the house got bigger and i was like
embarrassed of the house
and
um in high school
if i was if i overslept or just was
running late in the morning and wasn't
in time to skateboard to school
i would be forced to
catch a ride with dad in his chauffeur
driven car
and dad would be in the back seat of his
car with his chauffeur driving him
reading his newspaper
and i would
ride shotgun
and then when we pulled the school and i
got out i would hug the driver because i
didn't want anybody knowing i'd been
chauffeur driven to school wow i would
just talk to the driver and be like yeah
you know and i wouldn't even acknowledge
i just hugged the driver and get out and
like uh
you know i'd want them to drop me off
like a little further down the block
and and i was always looking to be
from pretty young age like i didn't like
having
kids over to our house because i didn't
want people to see
mom didn't want kids over um like it was
in my parenting life my house is the
house that every teenager within about
five miles just migrates to
and um
it's an open door you know we had a
fingerprint lock for a long time and
they're about 20 different fingers on in
the fingerprint lock um and uh
you know it's it's totally the house in
the neighborhood that all the kids hang
out at but when we were growing up
partly because of mom's drinking and her
you know image sensitivity and what the
kids might say to their parents or
whatever it was very you know like we
didn't have people over and if you asked
to have a sleepover it was a big deal
because mom would be weighing like oh
crap okay i'm gonna have to cook dinner
i'm gonna have to you know tidy up
there's no upside it's all downstairs
and so we just knew we kind of knew
better than to ask and i think that's
really common with
adult children of alcoholics when you
grow up that way it's fine that you
think of it that way because for me i
just didn't want to be at home i was
like like whose house like whose house
can i go to today yeah and it was pretty
much always abdullah's house
but yeah and but the thing is that you
know that's just very much
like like
mom and dad
for better or worse and you know i love
my dad you know i love my mom so i'm not
talking [ __ ] on anybody but the fact is
they thought that because they had money
that made them better than people
we are the apple did not fall that far
for either of us because although we're
not materialistic in that way
um
we did sort of learn that like lines are
for losers who can't figure out like a
way to avoid waiting in the line we're
not like british or canadian where we
queue up you know we we definitely look
for the angles and and things like speed
limits or no trespassing signs are
because you know some people aren't as
smart as we are and need like to be
protected from injury those are for the
dumb sheep
for people who aren't aware of their
limits but if you actually have physical
prowess or skills and and you are aware
of the risks and can do the cost-benefit
analysis then go proceed at your own
risk like it's a suggestion
the rules and the speed limits are a
suggestion that are very helpful for
people who might not be as smart as we
are for sure
working with steve like he'll give me
you know like five things to do and it's
like he doesn't give a [ __ ] about the
minutia of why or why not this person
said i can't he's like is it done yet or
is it not like
that you know i just i figured out shady
scott's just gonna make it happen yeah
yeah he doesn't care the progress bottom
line great when are we going
and that's that's all dad and and the
the social you know the the charming
holding court you know telling stories
like that's all mom
tushy is the secret to the most
enjoyable pooping possible they've got
this new product called tushy ace which
is a whole toilet seat that warms up it
warms the water that you blast your
butthole with because of course it's a
bidet you just get done pooping and the
seats warm you
push the remote control and then pull
you blast your butthole so clean that
one little square of toilet paper just
to dry it off and see that there's no
poop on the paper i'm telling you it's
my favorite go to hellotushy.como
for 10 off your order and if you don't
have tushy already then listen to me go
to hellotushi.como
for 10 off your order i'm telling you
it's my favorite sponsor of the wild
ride podcast